[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
all right and we are live laura cognito
here i love podcast lords of gaming.net
and who is this fine gentleman we have
in the realm of play nyc
uh hey everybody my name is patrick
mcaveeney i'm one of the developers of
shoulders of giants
[Music]
so tell us about shoulder of giants what
is the basic permits what is this game
about
yeah so shoulders of giants is an
approachable action roguelike
where you simultaneously control two
characters at once one is like an
awesome
uh sword-wielding mech and the other is
a sharp-shooting space rock who's
perched on his back
see scavenge for an arsenal of
randomized abilities and he used them to
unleash the light on a dark universe
awesome awesome well first of all the
game looks actually phenomenal i like
the
i love the art style of the game yeah
especially like the zuma
so tell us so he's in the robot like
what's going on here tell us what's
going on right now so basically this guy
is controlling
um this uh this like space frog this
person on top of this robot's back
um they're basically just trying to
destroy enemies in this level and
they're trying to destroy these like
dark monoliths that are going to spread
light
and then once they do that then they're
going to be able to unlock the the box
encounter which is generally at the top
of the level
um and they're finally they're finding
randomized abilities in the weapons
throughout
so i've noticed i'm seeing like a
teleport what up
what other abilities does the main
character have yeah so like
so basically every character so we kind
of pitches like you're controlling two
characters at once
so the abilities are split between the
frog and the robot
so like you start out with two basic
abilities you start with the dash
and then uh which is on the robot's end
and on the frog's end you start out
shooting i love the front for somebody
with a frog shoots it makes me laugh
um so he's also got a bubble shield
right now and all the abilities have
different randomized perks like this
this time the shield has an ability
where it will just like push
enemies away another perk is we actually
support up to four player co-op so the
other perk is like
uh all your all your allies will also
get a shield as well
so four players we're playing co-op and
we also have another mode which we call
best friend mode
so one person controls the frog one
person controls the robot i like that i
like that because
all i'm gonna say is artistically it
looks
cool because again with the frog and
then the robot so now this
this mode where you work together one
controls each
exactly and then they work in tandem
like the interesting thing about that is
it's
kind of crazy like because you have to
have a leap of faith like if you're the
frog you're not controlling where you're
going
right um but it's like
super fun um and it's like really fun to
watch people play it
it's very cool so as far as again where
are we at currently in development
as far as um you know how far are we out
are we just starting
how close is this game close to release
yeah so um we're kind of like at a point
where like the quarter game is done
we're
we're basically building out content and
a couple other different like
progression systems
so we're already getting a release of
like later next year like in the fall
sorry and what platforms are we
targeting initially
um so we're gonna be like targeting like
as many platforms as possible we don't
have any like firm like
announcements to make yet but we're like
definitely hoping like pc and the
consoles
nice that would be cool man very unique
concept i love the
of the idea of it the art style looks
very cool now as far as like stages like
we have an idea of like how many levels
we're looking at or
so um like the unique thing about our
game is like
the all the stages aren't like
necessarily regenerated but they're
going to be like a lot of randomized
elements
okay so you know our goal is like you
might not you might like come to the
same world but every time you come to
that world it's going to be different
right so um we don't have like a finite
number of that
yeah but like we want to have at least
like 20 hours of gameplay plus
where people don't feel like they've
like seeing anything that they do before
yeah
that's cool that's good especially the
procedurally generated aspect
seeing something fresh something new
consistently you don't get the same kind
of redundant
you know things that you're used to you
get to see a little different different
things in it now as far as like enemies
like are
because it's not like traditional state
like do we have like bosses
in a sense yes yeah so um every
every uh world has like a boss right so
you'll see
this player might get to the boss battle
i think he's like really close
um so all the bosses are um gonna be
like
like much more serious encounters and
you're always gonna get a piece of
reward once you clear a boss
last question as far as narrative
component
are we looking are we looking at a
full-fledged narrative or
is it more just about the gameplay
mechanics and not as much like
heavy on story so so one of the cool
things that we're working on now which
is not
in the demo is we're gonna have like a
hub world which npcs you can interact
with you can like buy things upgrade
things
um i don't know if you've seen in the
demo but there's like a guy that comes
in and gives you hints he's like a
little
ow so that l actually is going to be the
one that's telling you the story of the
game
so it's not like a heavy narrative game
by any means but you're going to be able
to visit this al and talk to him and
he's going to give you a piece of
information about the lore and the story
of the universe
nice last question obviously we're in a
pandemic with game dev
like how is that affecting you guys what
have you learned during this whole
situation
yeah so um you know for a while um you
know we were all working in an office
and then we like
weren't we were all working at home and
we just actually started recently coming
back into the office and working
together
and um you know working like remotely
like we were able to get a lot
done but like especially like early on
when you're in the korea phase it's
really hard to like brainstorm
and to like concept things together so
we found it like really beneficial to
work in the office again
together and that's been that's been
really great for us that's pretty
awesome man i love wow that looks cool
who the hell is that that's the boss
that i was talking about
wow this is cool this is cool go down
man when we look at we're very excited
looks pretty cool very unique shoulder
of giants
and i like that mode with two players
and one controls the robot one
controller
that's pretty cool we're super excited
and for people who want to support
where can they go to do like to find the
game to support the game yeah so you can
go to playsog.com
um and you can also follow us on twitter
of shoulders of g
shoulders of g y'all you already heard
what it is the man is here show the
giants go check it out very unique and
what to look out for at play nyc
[Music]
you